i could kiss you now colleen no no we
can't we're on the news
justin bieber is spookily accurate thank
you so much
that is incredible you want to look as
though you've done something wrong but
like
[Laughter]
i don't know if you heard but i'm not
bad no more
but i can still do this
okay so
i was a vegan for a while i was too you
were yeah yeah
and then
yeah you both have such great willpower
[Laughter]
you sure you don't want chocolate
i always say life is like a box of
chocolates
sure a whole lot of brown ones in there
the super bowl is sunday name one thing
that you would take to a party steve i
don't uh party as much because i'm a man
now i got like five little mustache
hairs and i'm bringing them all for you
girl
[Laughter]
i wish i was gay i would have more
option
last man i dated was a real dog oh an
attractive guy
no no he was actual dogs
thank you randall coming up more on the
situation downtown where the mayor is
scheduled to speak stay with us for
action 9 news i'm carol come dungeon
are we all going to sit like that
okay yeah chairs are uh there we go
yeah wow you all left your desk i'm
sorry you're right
you're right oh you're a lady
okay
why on earth would you throw eggs at
your neighbor's house
um
it's like a it's a tradition in canada
throwing eggs
i mean
no like um i thought my neighbor was a
chicken right so i was just returning
his kids
do you have any allies left no allies
it's mostly axis these days
except except
except for that french hunk macron
oh
you eat from the garbage yes really well
my thing is for real unless the food has
touched other garbage it's not garbage
i was looking forward to summer vacation
okay that's fine where are you going i
was going to go to east ukraine but now
is russia
so you know fmp amaretto
i think you mean fml no i mean fmp feed
me please i'm stuck
alan is a himalayan and you can find
himalayan on the couch
[Laughter]
you should do stand up
i bought him a bed he sleeps on the
floor
ungraceful
i'm grateful
i came home i told him i told him i've
i've i won an emmy you know and he was
like yeah go scoop the crap for my oh
come on
a little ass wife
he deserves a pinch
that is my nipple and i think you know
that i have been
showering with a couple paper towels
paper towels in the office that i share
with aidy bryant
and uh gosh i'm just praying because one
one of these days she's just gonna walk
in and find me like
it didn't hurt it was like i'm sorry
pardon me sharon it's kind of like that
no harm no foul i'm worried about you it
just seems like you're dealing with a
lot well tell me about it it's like
everyone in europe is having this rowdy
slumber party and i'm the mean mom who
has to send them straight to bed without
their radishes
filamentous
glossy say an enemy
nice
big picture
i bought two
orbital sanders all these um
orbital sanders well you need one a flat
and a detailer okay
this guy
obviously never touched a piece of wood
[Laughter]
my sister and i were athletes as
children our favorite sport was running
away from angry wolf
i won the gold she won the silver god
rest her song
[Music]
breathing in the smoke and clearing up
my mind
i have to say i'm such a fan i have all
your movies oh
and i have no idea who either of us is
nice
nope
no no penelope it's phytomorphogenesis
refrigerator no
and how did they instruct you to urinate
was that telepathically uh no no i uh i
woke up i had to pee like a camel
so uh
i started peeing and one of the gray
aliens slapped the wall
and pointed the bowl so i got the hint i
kind of ducked walked over
on the way to fame was there anything
that you did along the way to get there
that hurt your dignity killed a man
earnest of all creation what we would
call god
what
these fancy cats are seeing god
meanwhile i'm starting phase two which
is me sitting on a stool
while 40 grey aliens take turns
did you have a response
[Applause]
not a
not a response more of a request can
america vote right now
i was going to try to do a dang judy
impression oh really which i've been
trying to do for a long time but
it's very hard you can do anyone
i don't know it's sort of
but
it's not accurate but it's
there's something like
up in the nose
about huh
[Music]
all right
god i hate dancing
i wish i hadn't danced in my first
episode
which i just sat the heck down and had a
smoothie
do you have hobbies girl and she was
like i love to go to the beach i love to
paddleboard i love
to watch my children run on the sand
i
i love to go to the maldives i love it
do you have a hubby kate and i was like
i watched dateline
my name's sheila somash
you can remember that because if you mix
up all the letters it spells whole ass
vag
if you weren't acting what would you be
doing
carpentry
10 000
carpentry okay specifically perhaps
cabinet making
but maybe just um general carpentry or
refinishing furniture also quite
interested in plumbing and electrical
she's on hgtv all day i love
i mean to see the fruits the physical
fruits the wooden fruits of one's labor
after the day
i feel would be very satisfying
and having refinished a few pieces of
furniture